[Music]
albert camus
grew up surrounded by violence his
homeland of algeria
was mired in conflict between native
algerians and colonising french
europeans
he lost his father in the first world
war and was deemed unfit to fight
in the second battling tuberculosis in
france
and confronting the war's devastation as
a resistance journalist
camus grew despondent he couldn't fathom
any meaning behind all this endless
bloodshed
and suffering he asked if the world was
meaningless
could our individual lives still hold
value
many of camus contemporaries were
exploring similar questions
under the banner of a new philosophy
called existentialism
existentialists believe people were born
as blank slates
each responsible for creating their
life's meaning amidst a chaotic world
but camus rejected their school of
thought
he argued all people were born with a
shared human nature
that bonded them toward common goals one
such goal
was to seek out meaning despite the
world's arbitrary cruelty
camus viewed humanity's desire for
meaning
and the universe's silent indifference
as two
incompatible puzzle pieces and
considered
trying to fit them together to be
fundamentally absurd
this tension became the heart of camus
philosophy of the absurd
which argued that life is inherently
futile
exploring how to live without meaning
became the guiding question
behind camus early work which he called
his
cycle of the absurd the star of this
cycle
and camus first published novel offers a
rather bleak response
the stranger follows merco an
emotionally detached young
man who doesn't attribute much meaning
to anything
he doesn't cry at his mother's funeral
he supports his neighbor's scheme to
humiliate a woman
he even commits a violent crime
but mersof feels no remorse for him
the world is pointless and moral
judgment
has no place in it this attitude creates
hostility
between mercur and the orderly society
he inhabits
slowly increasing his alienation until
the novel's
explosive climax unlike his spurned
protagonist
camus was celebrated for his honest
philosophy
the stranger catapulted him to fame and
camus continued producing works
that explored the value of life amidst
absurdity
many of which circled back to the same
philosophical question
if life is truly meaningless is
committing suicide the only
rational response camus answer was an
emphatic
no there may not be any explanation for
our unjust world
but choosing to live regardless is the
deepest expression
of our genuine freedom camus explains
this
in one of his most famous essays which
centers on the greek myth
of sisyphus sisyphus was a king who
cheated the gods
and was condemned to endlessly roll a
boulder
up a hill the cruelty of his punishment
lies in its singular futility but camus
argues all of humanity is in the same
position
and only when we accept the
meaninglessness of our lives
can we face the absurd with our heads
held
high as camus says when the king chooses
to begin
his relentless task once more one must
imagine sisyphus happy camus
contemporaries weren't so accepting of
futility
many existentialists advocated for
violent revolution
to upend systems they believed were
depriving people of
agency and purpose camus responded with
his second set of work
the cycle of revolt in the rebel
he explored rebellion as a creative act
rather than a destructive one
camus believed that inverting power
dynamics only led
to an endless cycle of violence
instead the way to avoid needless
bloodshed
is to establish a public understanding
of our shared human nature
ironically it was this cycle of
relatively peaceful ideas
that triggered his fallout with many
fellow writers and philosophers
despite the controversy camus began work
on his most lengthy
and personal novel yet an
autobiographical work
entitled the first man
the novel was intended to be the first
piece in a hopeful new direction
the cycle of love but in 1960
camus suddenly died in a car accident
that can only be described
as meaningless and absurd while the
world never saw his cycle of love
his cycles of revolt and absurdity
continue to resonate with readers today
his concept of absurdity has become a
part of world literature
20th century philosophy and even pop
culture
today camus remains a trusted guide for
moments of uncertainty
his ideas defiantly imbuing a senseless
world
with inspiration rather than defeat
[Music]
do you handle life's challenges as a
stoic
or a cynic find out which philosophy
represents you
by choosing one of these videos
[Music]
you